[Music]
the recent launch of the world's most
powerful icebreaker was a proud moment
for many Russians in virtue I can do the
price deeply I see fatima stop resisting
table glove me var scooter Java Atlanta
consciously I'm completely
cinematographers Virginia as the polar
ice melt northern nations are rushing to
exert their control and with its new
fleet of modern ice breakers Russia is
way out in front
this is a year ow it's able to crunch
through almost three meters of ice and
it's nuclear powered engines give it
almost unlimited endurance
Russia has two other ships just like
this one already and six even larger
icebreakers on the way - the Arctic
Ocean which is opposite IGAs a step
Tahiti was my limit like Easter dad let
our stable carbon is ogw yield promote /
succeed off there's no discussion here
about a climate emergency the talk is
only about opportunity Colada Canada
needs icebreakers to compete taunted the
Russian shipyard official so our
shipyard can build them for you Russia's
economy is almost entirely dependent on
oil and gas and with an estimated twenty
two percent of the world's undiscovered
reserves in the Arctic Russia is pushing
to unlock all it can
at this year's Arctic forum President
Vladimir Putin said the Icebreaker fleet
is key to getting resources to market
year round through the northern sea
passage over the top of Russia do not
silly sushi stand and resist is beyond
gross a period
Tolga policy of more booty though why's
mr. million of poon the advanced Academy
Board seeing the gigantic new industrial
projects really drives home the scale of
Russia's ambitions for the Arctic this
is the centrepiece Yamal LNG it's an
enormous liquefied natural gas plant
built on Siberia's frozen tundra it's 70
degrees north a few months back our crew
got a quick tour of the year old
facility that has its own Airport
seaport and it's large enough to
accommodate 30,000 fly-in workers we
also saw the christoph to Margaery it's
a new ice capable tanker based here year
round thanks to the thinning Arctic ice
[Music]
thousands of kilometers to the west
Murmansk already the world's largest
Arctic community with a population of
over 300,000 is also expanding this vast
site will be a new port with a rail link
to the south but all of these
potentially lucrative Arctic
opportunities also come with great
challenges and great risks environmental
journalist Annika Riva grew up here and
she worries about how these projects
will affect the delicate northern
ecosystem I've seen how bad we can do I
still I haven't seen how we can improve
it
[Music]
pure Eva took us to the town of Nikhil
it's the site of a metal smelter that's
been belching away for 70 years the slow
growing arctic trees nearby are
blackened and poisoned by sulfur dioxide
emissions the lifeless landscape may
take decades to recover if it ever does
[Music]
the nature heals itself very slowly and
only if you decrease the amount of
production the emissions were so huge
that it will take quite some time to
rehabilitate the territory there's
concern as well about the impact of all
that new arctic shipping some here even
tout the northern sea as a possible
rival for the Suez Canal as it cuts down
the trip from Europe to Asia by 10 days
but barely anyone lives along the route
and there are very few search and rescue
stations in the Arctic in case of
trouble what if if there would be a
disaster and someone some ship would
sink and it would be somewhere in the I
know Siberian waters where will you
bring the people along with the
industrial buildup there's been a
military one too strategically the
attraction of Russia to the Arctic is
evident Japan lies to the east and NATO
to the west but up here
Russia is unchallenged
Russia has been refitting soviet-era
military bases to demonstrate its
willingness to enforce its Arctic claims
whether that's evidence of aggressive
intentions or legitimate defensive
posturing Russia has been very open
about what it's up to in the Arctic
nor has the Kremlin shied away from
inviting international experts to
scrutinize the projects British
ecologist thierry Vincent callahan was
on the same tour of Yamal and the nearby
city of santa card and he came away
conflicted on one hand we saw an
exceptional development in the Arctic
which is not easy to accomplish it's a
huge development and that development
does some good but at the same time I'm
an ecologist so an environmentalist so I
worry about losing tundra forgets
another big oil and gas development
he says industrial activity in the
Arctic
especially emissions and particles from
stacks can dramatically increase the
rate of global warming that finds its
way onto the Greenland ice sheet onto
the pure ice and snow of the High Arctic
Island so the snow starts melting faster
[Music]
over the generations Russia's northern
indigenous people have been hurt more
than most from Arctic development in
Soviet times many were forcibly removed
from their communities to make room for
military bases today most have their
livelihoods tied to reindeer or caribou
hurting
the fragile schedule irska you might
have several inaudible nineteen-year-old
Maxine Oh Cotto told us they're learning
to live with the disruption to migration
routes and all of the new industry but
when we went to the home of the Sami
people about 200 kilometres from romance
a very different story green use near
solution that was not just to mr. cm
fish in Calverton et you stole someone
galley me come when you boot in Kiryas
not understand you were a CID valentina
subpoena is an activist here the sami
number only around 1700 people in russia
for their communities have been here for
thousands of years good evening I don't
what I need to do act yeah I need your
soccer I need you to if it was done like
it's just a cassette here
she told us their experience dealing
with big corporations has not been good
you make her tell you what II mean about
a capricious ago so Vanya steady telling
me a promotion this year a Thomas Tobin
would you like a pillow new blood cell
at the geekness data washed abominably
for Magadheera yet here some schooling
teaches that it's not astonishing study
discovery we're this Arctic landscape in
Canada
there'd be perhaps years of assessments
and then years of debate but in Russia
the Putin government faced with a
sluggish economy and crippling foreign
sanctions has said everything shipping
LNG resource development is now all full
speed ahead
I think unfortunately the world will
need oil and gas for decades so all the
countries who have oil and gas there
they will develop it even in the Arctic
and they will go further and further to
the Arctic to to continue developing it
there's still much that could go wrong
with Russia's big Arctic batch energy
prices to crash
maybe alternative fuels will gain
traction but if not Russia and its new
fleet of icebreakers are in a commanding
position to call the shots in the Arctic
Chris Brown CBC News in Murmansk
[Music]